and this is like his special skill so
well we'll see what happens and uh
pragananda has kicked off and he's moved
the queen pawn to move two squares
forward yup so one d4 to start this game
when they met last month it was colors
reversed magnus actually had white there
and he lost eventually and magnus does
he know the game has started he does
he brings his night out so very standard
stuff pregnant just trying to occupy the
center with pawns here so magnus what's
he going to adopt as a strategy in the
opening okay he creates the fiancee is
he going to go for the grunfeld defense
a really counter-attacking opening but
very direct or is he going to play uh
maybe
okay he does go for the grandfather's
gonna say the king's indian defense just
allowing white to take the whole center
that's also equally risky and we see a
trade of pawns knights also leaving the
board wow and moving all over the place
here yeah these two players big experts
in this opening pragnanda as white
against the grunfeld defense he won a
really nice game just a couple of months
ago in vaikansei against the swedish
number one neil's gondalia so he has
fond memories of this opening magnus
occasionally uses this opening as black
but i remember having a conversation
with him in a taxi in 2010 and he said
he hates the grinfeld defense there's
too much to memorize too much to learn
and uh
here we go already quite a rare move
bring black's bishop out normally we see
black castle the king away to safety and
uh if you look at the center of the
board as well white has the pawns there
occupying a lot of space black has to
chip away at those white pawns from the
side from afar using the two bishops and
okay eventually black does castle the
king so it's still very tense it's all
about whether white can maintain the
center if he does then pregnant will
have the advantage if black can maybe
trade off white central pawns then black
should be okay okay do you have a
favorite opening kira
uh
yeah no i i i do like to play a bit
sicilian i'm trying to experiment with
that but i'm not very good at it but i'm
just wondering about this one because in
my experience you talked about castling
and if you cast a bit late it's kind of
like yeah and i never get to do it
yeah exactly and uh i think that's why
pregnant now has just sacrificed to pawn
actually uh because it was
the number one priority for white to get
the king castled otherwise as you
mentioned it would have been too late
otherwise the white king might have come
under heavy fire and magnus he's really
being greedy look at that black queen
she's offside wow not really doing too
much she's out in siberia somewhere just
kind of honored her own adventure but
she has grabbed one pawn in the process
so actually prague he's being ambitious
he's sacrificed to porn and
look at this pushing pawns in the center
he's gaining space and i can tell you
this is a new move um it's not actually
normal for
white to in this position
push that pawn forward it's much more
normal to actually attack the queen with
the rook
and here we're now in analysis territory
who has studied this line uh what do you
think david
yeah i mean this it might be a brand new
move but it's quite a common idea at
least white just pushing pawns as far
forward down the board as possible also
you look at this white pawn in the
center it could be joined by the pawn
next to it and we could see a past pawn
being very created very very shortly
meanwhile i don't like the fact that
black's queen is stuck out there on her
own there's a big risk of her firstly
getting trapped and secondly she's going
to have to lose a lot of time kind of
rejoining
the rest of her pieces later on she's
going to have to retreat at least twice
over the next few moves so
pawn sacrifices i'm a bit materialistic
i'm too scared to go for them with white
but here white has fantastic
compensation for that sacrificed pawn
and magnus needs to speed up and catch
up with development so therefore he
brings his knight
into the game
and uh yeah ivanka
as you know i'm
kind of a grunfeld connoisseur i've been
playing it my whole life as black but
the older i get the more i think it's
just too risky white has too many pawns
in the center of the board and uh yeah
again as mentioned it's not necessarily
magnus's favorite type of position so
really clever opening choice here from
pragnanda and
after this trade
white gets the bishop pair and wow okay
he actually captures back with the pawn
here pregnant
look at those pawns now on the f-file
that doubled
that's a very controversial decision but
he does have even more pawns now
controlling central squares
this one is already promising i think
we're going to get a lot of excitement
in this game nice it's not one of those
dull maybe solid uh openings i would
have expected from magnus after losing
last month to prague i think he's uh
fighting fire with fire here
okay let's see what happens yeah for me
it's like a sign of confidence from
pragnando that he actually
recaptures that piece
by actually breaking the rules because
often you don't want to be playing this
type of move because you know look at
the white king doesn't have too many
protections around it however you know
as david mentioned the black queen
totally offside
but uh yeah i like i like what fragranda
has done actually i think it's very
brave very bold and i applaud it nice
and if you look at the clock times as
well he's actually got more time than he
started with pregnant so to me that says
he studied it before maybe with his
coach that we interviewed yesterday
ramesh
maybe he just thought okay magnus is
least comfortable when he's being
attacked
we've seen him lose a few games on the
tour when the black king comes under
fire or when his opponent is pushing
everything forward
so he's definitely playing against the
playing against the man not only against
the board and there we go the black
queen losing a bit more time going back
where she came from all right well
interesting game we're heading in too
and uh kyra i wanted to ask you because
obviously being norwegian you said you
played chess as a kid
and then
you know kids came and work came and you
know time trouble to to have time to
play but what did it mean that magnus
became world champion that a norwegian
became world champion in 2013 that did
that spark your interest again
yeah definitely yeah it came back and i
think it's done that for for a lot of my
friends and uh yeah actually half of the
norwegian population yeah so because i i
just played once in a while
uh with friends typically uh some late
evenings uh but then after magnus
starting to win and they start to show
it you know live on tv yeah i started to
play as often as i can so i think and i
think that's for many people yeah yeah
yeah how's it real right i remember i
was a student when he became world
champion
suddenly you know our conversation every
day would be about chess we were like
what what is this what's happening to us
you know exactly i mean now i'm thinking
i need to take my daughter to a chess
club she's seven so it's about time but
she's not that interested my son who's
four is more interested
but
maybe i wouldn't have thought that ten
years ago you know i would just have
parked that idea you know whole chess id
but now i'm like i'm going to go to the
local chess club as soon as i can wow
with at least one of them
and well reminds me of your interview
with henry carlson ivanka he also around
was it like four years old with magnus
he noticed some qualities in magnus yeah
he noticed some personality traits in
magnus that he thought hang on you know
maybe magnus will be a good chess player
but he actually said the first time he
tried to teach magnus and his older
sister alan some chess it was a disaster
it did not go well you know
and he was thought how could i be so
wrong about this and uh you know they
didn't really enjoy it but then i think
because henrik was so interested in the
game that when uh
henrik introduced the game later on the
the children were a lot a little bit
older and they could understand things
more and it kind of bit both of them and
both of them became really really
interested in the game and magnus
frankly became obsessed he was studying
it and just absorbing chess
24 hours of the day yeah i i remember
henrikh he said that he would play
against magnus with one pawn
and he would win
with his one pawn he would be able to to
queen it and just win the game
so it's nice to hear that even magnus
carlsen has lost yeah and i think a lot
of our viewers actually have a similar
story they learn when they're young from
parents or grandparents and then life
gets in the way things happen but they
come back to it in later life and that's
for me that's the main thing i mean you
talk about henrik cass and his sister i
mean they're such a close family and i
think chess is one thing that really uh
kind of helped them bond uh at a young
age so that's nice to hear i think you
should definitely take your son and
daughter to the chess club definitely
and but i want to like my dad because
when i beat him first time yeah he never
played again
so i didn't have that you know close
coach at home
i i will stay in there as possible yeah
yeah
now you definitely
don't don't give up the game when your
child beats you in fact you should take
the inspiration from an australian grad
master actually because he was really
into chess at an early age but then he
kind of you know life got in the way but
then his son started becoming interested
in chess and so he thought oh
hang on a second i actually have to help
my son get better because there are no
coaches
so he actually
picked up the game and started studying
the game to get better just to help his
child
wow yeah and uh together i think he had
the father became like a quite strong
player like it became a feed a master
which is around about 2300 and the sun
is now uh one of the the country's top
ground masters so who is it uh it's uh
anton smenov ah from australia
wow what a story i love that yeah and so
cool with chess as well it's never too
late right no but i think it is a good
idea to to learn when you're a kid like
with the language right your brain just
absorbs it better
well i i'm
i'm not sure actually
because uh i think when you're an adult
you can actually understand the
strategies much better that's true and
you can understand how chess is the
language
my apologies live tv
[Laughter]
and
you know i just think that when you're
on adult you can process everything that
you need to be doing you can actually
take a look back at the board and you
can understand where the pieces should
go you can remember things that people
have said to you in a way that children
can't you know children often just go
yeah yeah understood i understood and
then they repeat the mistake maybe about
20 or 30 times and then the message gets
through yeah and uh adults they don't
play as quickly either which is uh which
is very good because children play
sometimes a little bit too quickly
yeah well uh pragma 16 not a kid anymore
he didn't play fast in this move
thinking for three minutes i think yes
queen three four minutes and when we had
his coach on yesterday ramesh he said
one of prague's biggest biggest
weaknesses is time trouble actually
thinking a bit too much and when i
played him a few months ago as well
normally i'm the one shorter on time but
i think there were several moments he
spent 30 40 minutes on one move so
okay this move i'm not a huge fan let's
jump into the position to show
what pregnant's thinking is behind just
pushing his queen forward only one
square
on the last turn this pawn was actually
under fire from the bishop and by the
queen so it's attacked twice only
defended once by white's rook that's why
prague has lifted his queen up to just
add extra protection to this pawn
however white's whole plan the whole
reason he's a pawn down is because he
wants to push everything forward so to
me the most natural would have been to
push this pawn forward maybe create this
nice little pawn chain and actually
magnus has just stopped that um just but
just before this uh
before we go into this move another plan
for white to push this pawn forward and
then the central pawn and uh if for
example black had just wasted time uh
magnus of course not doing this then
suddenly white obtains just the
strongest pawns you will ever see but
the reason now um i wasn't such a fan of
this move by prague is because he has
allowed magnus after pushing his queen
forward to block things up and this
looks like a porn sacrifice by black it
is a pawn sacrifice but the biggest
priority is to stop white from pushing
forward himself and if pragnal takes
this pawn with his bishop then there
will be consequences you open up lines
for the black rooks and suddenly black's
rook is looking at the bishop and the
pawn behind it also the black knight
might jump into the center hitting the
bishop hitting some pawns and suddenly
things are opening up but maybe just not
while prague is ready so uh really
interesting move there and magda's
played it quite quickly he was thinking
while prague
was running down on the clock so this is
the current position i'm expecting to
maybe see this pawn captured i don't
think you can allow it to sit in your
half of the board for too long because
then suddenly black is the one rolling
with his pawns down the board what we
call a porn storm but uh after it is
captured i think the rook will slide
across and prague once he moves the
bishop back we will see magnus get
greedy once again by grabbing this pawn
with his bishop maybe even with his rook
and things are opening up things are
getting traded but i think prague missed
an opportunity to start rolling forward
with his horns there just
maybe just a bit too hesitant and again
spending quite a bit of time on the
clock yeah and uh the final position
that you showed in your variation to me
it looked like black was almost a clear
pawn up yeah and
it seemed like the timing had uh passed
for white and uh i just what's advantage
sorry that uh it just lies in the center
of the board yeah that's why you have to
push bones in the center and you
mentioned black being upon up black
actually has a two versus zero advantage
of pawns if you look on the left side so
if everything else gets traded off those
two black horns are just going to slowly
walk up the wood and uh promote to a new
queen later so
yeah ivanka
not such a fan of prague's decision
no i'm not a fan of uh the decision
primarily because of uh magnus's move i
mean it's quite an instructive idea
actually
and
just simply uh trying to put a pawn on
white side of the board and just there
being a wedge there preventing this pawn
expansion but one thing i did
wonder was whether
pragananda could kind of pivot and just
go back to his normal idea of just
expanding
on
the center yeah those double pawns that
white has on that f line one of them can
step forward you can try and push a pawn
in the center later to try and block out
black's bishop if you look at black's
bishop that's what we call the
fianchetto and it's on a fantastic
diagonal as we mentioned staring down at
some pawns controlling all the dark
squares um so you need to block that guy
out the game and yeah as you mentioned
you rank i think two only really two
choices here either you remove that
black pawn from the board because it's
just a thorn in your side or you push
pawns but he finds a third option prague
sliding his queen across maybe this was
his idea all along but magnus making a
face surprised by that one
i must admit i'm surprised too it wasn't
on my radar it's not normally uh kind of
a conventional idea to put your queen
opposite your opponent's bishop yes
there's a pawn in the way yes you're
attacking a pawn with the white queen um
on this line but it feels a bit
superficial
that can easily deal with that threat
so what could be his plan well i think
it's like uh like david mentioned like a
one-track mind you know basically he's
thinking
if black uh is careless and maybe pushes
the pawn that's under fire two squares
or even one square then the white rook
will just attack the queen and the queen
doesn't have a great place to go to
uh that's it
and the problem is is that's a very
simple threat but it can easily be
handled as david mentioned yeah so this
one attacked and the line ivanka was
mentioning there's this pawn it's under
fire it might as well march forward
protected by its queen then price idea
surely is to bring the rook across to be
honest i'm not sure this even works yes
you're attacking the queen but now
you've lost protection once more of this
pawn so black could actually play queen
takes pawn defended by her bishop and
i guess prague wants to capture this
pawn now we'll see a trade of some pawns
both queens getting a bit active but
it feels just all wrong for white
somehow the queen can even move out the
way
she can offer a trade for example or she
can maybe even step down the board
attacking this bishop attacking this
rook
and
i don't know prague's lost control
earlier all his pieces were centralized
kind of bunched up together protecting
each other suddenly the queen is out on
her own um this rook has mentioned just
on a bad square so i'm expecting this
from magnus just to pick up this pawn
and push it but the other option would
be to maybe a bit safer drop the queen
back protect the pawn next to it and
keeping an eye on this guy as well
okay so peter with with your level if
you came to um you know the good night
and saw
two people playing this position would
you be able to sort of say oh i want to
play with the black pieces here
yeah i mean i i was thinking the last
one you you mentioned that uh pull the
queen back um to the sea um sea lion
because then you can also go
quite quickly over to the other line
because i i think that in the long run i
think the the white king is a bit open
isn't it isn't he yeah on the g line
there so that's that but that's that's
my would be my long-term uh goal but
then you also i mean the the a and the b
pawns of magnus
um
you mentioned uh some some moves there
where where um white is actually then
starting to pick out those and i think
also that would be good for white right
yeah quite possibly i mean white would
love for example to use the queen and
grab a couple of pawns but um yeah it
just it's all about timing right now and
uh magnus you can see right now he's got
his kind of calculation face on he's
trying to work out two or three steps in
advance but i think if he's unsure about
the evaluation as you mentioned there
about his pawns disappearing then he'll
take a step back and he'll take that
safe option and
yeah you also mentioned white's king
you're right the pawn structure around
it is shattered and
especially if the if the black knight
somehow creeps forward towards that
white king
and then you combine the queen with it
then prague will regret having opened up
his king at the moment i guess he's not
too worried just because there are no
black pieces around
but uh definitely something long-term
for prague to keep an eye on so yeah
well spotted because uh
magnus he's going to be having these
things in his mind he's going to have
sneaky ideas later on and
yeah it's too slow then those ideas
might become reality yeah he's uh
definitely in evaluation mode right and
i i think he's calculating the line that
you highlighted
he's trying to sit there and make an
assessment because
the resulting position at the end yes it
could be good for black but you know
it's it could also be good for white if
you makes it more messy that's the only
thing
so safe option retreating the black
queen uh messier option but maybe quite
good for black would be to push some
pawns yeah so that's well that's why we
talk about styles and chess every player
has different preferences styles
um magnus likes to keep control if he
can in general so
yeah the more i think about it the more
i'm on your side there
producing the queen
retreating the queen is something like
you know it's a move that uh like david
says you have in your pocket yeah it's
it's a good move it's uh it's a it's
okay to have you can always fall back on
that if you decide on the more forcing
line that isn't quite the right move for
you
now i have a question about so we see
doubled pawns and next to the white
double pawns we have double bishops
is double bishops actually a good thing
i mean they will be controlling a lot of
lines yeah um in general i mean
especially here white's bishops are
fantastic um because i guess together
they'll control all the color complexes
and they'll control all the squares
especially if they're quite centralized
bishops are great long range pieces so
black's bishop also good on this long
diagonal but white bishops have the
potential to control both sides of the
board and okay
he does go for the messier option yeah
the more ambitious option but nice
spotted killer yes yeah
and okay now we are definitely expecting
white's rook to slide across to attack
the black queen because
otherwise
prague's whole idea of kind of switching
his queen over to this left side doesn't
really have a purpose so um if he's
consistent pragnal will bring his rook
across and attack the black queen
and he needs to play quite fast now he
uh has spent a lot of time but they are
well minus spent like four minutes on
his previous move so it's not dramatic
on the clock but he did spend quite a
long time on two more stair prac yeah
and i guess the players i mean
especially at this top level or the
players we see they're very good at
sensing critical moments so um that was
just a it's more stylistic decision safe
option or really aggressive and that's
why magnus invested so much time there
normally we don't see it from him
normally he's very instinctive and he
likes to stay ahead on the clock if he
can but
i think it was a good moment to stop and
pause
for a while
but if you play at 11 o'clock in the
night how does that affect you
well it depends on what kind of person
you are and uh
i would assume that the pragananda has
actually and he has in fact attacked the
queen with his rook so uh it just
depends you know um if you're a morning
person this is going to be very very
difficult for you and you probably need
to do some training for instance you
probably actually have to
in preparation for this event actually
start playing at 10 30 p.m at night you
know so that your brain gets used to
working on chest as opposed to sleeping
because you have to be fresh right if
you're going to play chess for four
hours like these players are doing yeah
so i mean their preparation beforehand
would be just you know
waking up later and then
10th come to 10 30 p.m study chess yeah
and then you have to study chess i guess
for five hours and uh yeah
but it's it's difficult mm-hmm it is
difficult uh
okay so your favorite time of day 10 30
p.m yeah to start playing chess you
would thrive in this tournament david
yeah and uh okay meanwhile as predicted
this trade of pawns both queens getting
a bit greedy there and grabbing the
opponent's pawns and uh yeah i remember
having a chat with magnus uh years and
years ago and he said um that he'd done
a bit of research and apparently the the
mind is at its kind of most sharp most
focused four to six hours after waking
up so imagine if you start at 10 30 p.m
and you've been awake since eight in the
morning it's impossible so you
definitely i mean chess players in
general are quite nocturnal but you
definitely have to
plan for that and as ivanka says
acclimatize okay this move
very surprising i must admit from magnus
he's brought his knight out the knight
was attacked by the white queen um but
this knight can be captured in some
scenarios by white's dark square bishop
also it's a bit loose yes it's defended
by a pawn right now but that black pawn
defending the black knight
is under fire itself
it's a bit shaky and just instinctively
it feels like
an okay move but maybe not the move
magnus wanted to play maybe just he's
being practical didn't want to invest
another five minutes on uh calculating
sharp what should he have done
would you have preferred to see it go
the other way
backwards or yeah i was thinking maybe
you don't even have to defend this
knight which is under fire i thought
maybe you could start counter-attacking
as i mentioned one option it is
complicated one option is just bring the
queen down one square counter-attacking
against white's bishop and here that
idea of breaking towards the white king
would be in effect if the black knight
is captured for example you could take
this bishop now you can start sneakily
attacking these doubled pawns creeping
over towards this king it doesn't feel
too safe anymore with the black queen
nearby and the other purpose of course
behind this black queen move would be to
unblock the bishop's diagonal to
actually hit this rook in the corner
with the bishop the reason magnus didn't
go for this maybe is because you have to
calculate a lot further you have to
think okay what happens if this bishop
drops back to attack the black queen
will the black queen get trapped it's
running out of squares and it gets very
very complicated i mean the night is
under fire the queen is under fire maybe
magnus just thought okay none of this
nonsense let's just keep
everything nice and protected which is a
good kind of practical idea especially
in speeches rapid chess if this was a
long game magnus maybe it would have
spent time on this queen move but he
brings his knight to the side and as
mentioned it can be captured by white's
bishop but here after a recapture
suddenly the rooks are looking at each
other and after a rook trade and uh i
think white's queen would just be too
far away here and it's all about the
dark squares black's queen could start
sneaking towards the white king
so we do see a couple of quick moves
instead
uh the white rook switching back again
where it came from and now black's queen
retreating
i'm starting to like black's position
again um i know i wasn't so sure about
this black move uh this black knight
move but again once it's captured
suddenly the queen is super near the
white king starting an attack already
yeah i have to say i really love this
night move um big fan of it because it
sets that strategical trap that yeah you
mentioned you know yeah you entice white
to perhaps exchange of the dark square
bishops and then it would be opposite
color bishops and uh black would just be
completely supreme
on the dark squares and just to show
your point ivanka uh for example here
say the black queen checks suddenly
opposite color bishops but this bishop
blocked in by its own pawns staring at
its own pawns and suddenly again it's
white is careless then his checkmate on
the dark squares the queen and bishop
are going to line up and the king is
just doomed
so yeah yeah opposite color bishops
would not be whites uh in white's favor
here and and the thing is though it's
it's a really a perpetual trap that he's
kind of setting he's talk to white he's
saying hey if you ever want to win back
the pawn that is sitting on the c4
square and it's going to be a menacing
pawn especially if it advances one
square forward
well
you're going to give me the dark squares
so what is it are you going to let me
live with the extra pawn or you're going
to give up your dark squares and this is
really really very unpleasant i if i
were pragnando right now i might be
panicking yeah also a really clever
choice of square for the black queen
because the white bishop the light
squared bishop can actually capture this
born but suddenly it would lose
protection of one of the doubled pawns
and the queen you can't let it anywhere
near your king like this and the queen
attacking this pawn this pawn
i think magnus is really clever there
with his choice of square and as
seavanka mentioned slight panic maybe
for prague i think he needs to just
shore up and defend his king's position
maybe by pushing a pawn forward maybe by
even lifting his king up the board just
to protect the pawns around it and
actually he has done just that uh so
still very tense black still needs to
find a way to improve but as civilian
mentioned again this pawn
is going to advance and it's going to be
very very difficult for white to keep an
eye on it for the rest of the game okay
so the bar isn't too excited you know
about it it's saying roughly draw so in
human terms is this much more would you
put the bar much more over it in
human scans i personally would put the
bar
quite far from magnus's side okay i
would even say maybe
close to one porn advantage in computer
talk um i just think magnus has a great
shot at uh
putting white under pressure and making
um pragananda have
just enticing him to make a mistake
yeah after all if we do a quick count
black is one pawn up so plus one for
black according to the computer would be
very logical but this is the type of
position where if white wins the pawn
back the evaluation bar will just be
roughly 0.0 around the middle but if
black keeps the pawn the advantage will
grow and grow with every move so there
we go okay he does indeed just put his
pawn on a square it's protected
so the black queen black bishop really
keeping that pawn under their gaze and
here we go prague's idea is to just push
in the center he should have done this i
feel maybe five ten moves ago but better
late than never and uh if the white e
pawn steps forward now uh it will attack
the black queen it will cut the
connection with the black queen as well
and the bishop to that very far advanced
black pawn
and uh simultaneously the bar went up
for magnus
as did our donation bar for unicef we
have passed 53
thousand dollars now and the fundraiser
so thank you to everyone for uh joining
in and
and keep donating it's so important
right kiddo i mean
for people sitting at home seeing
pictures on the news
it's it's very hard to to find a way to
help what is the best way for people to
help organizations like unicef do their
job the best is to donate more yeah
actually
and to buy the twinkie winky suit
for a lot of money that's the best way i
mean right now we're seeing a lot of a
lot of uh goodwill yeah we're seeing a
lot of hearts and warm hearts in norway
but in the long run it's money to
organizations
that are on the ground that is the most
solid solid help professional and know
what because obviously psychologically
as well for children experiencing bombs
experiencing fleeing
i guess it needs professional help to
make sure they're not traumatized for
life as well no definitely you need
professional help and also you need uh
equipment professional equipment i mean
you need real medicines in the hospitals
you need
midwives being there to deliver children
and this is it costs money uh of course
and so and you have a lot of
organizations like unicef and some
others that are really good at what
they're doing and doing it for unicef
has been doing it for more than 75 years
really wow
yeah that's what we all can do donate to
help eunice help help the people of
ukraine this is the charity cup so it is
about donating and of course also about
chess chess community coming together
and moves coming out yeah moves coming
out and we've just seen what we call on
passant so black's pawn advancing two
squares but white was able to capture it
as if it just moved one square um so
yeah
often if you can play on pass on you
want to just to stop your opponent
opponent gaining space bypassing you uh
but after this trade of pawns we've seen
black's queen dodge out the way and
white now try and block things up in the
center with his pawns and now there is a
bit of a threat in the position white's
rook just wants to step up two squares
and capture this annoying uh black past
pawn um so i'm expecting magnus to maybe
just defend that with one of his rooks
uh one of the black rooks could slide
across to the c file and just defend
this pawn you don't really want to allow
white to capture it because then
suddenly white will have the bishop pair
and no other real disadvantages in the
position i like what prague's actually
done with the white king it still looks
a bit vulnerable but the light squared
bishop the white light square bishop can
plug any holes there can block any
checks
coming in in the near future so still
very tense and
prague he's tenacious he's also he's a
great fighter as all young players are
and
he's making it difficult for magnus to
utilize to convert his one-point
advantage
now it looks more solid now now yeah so
how do you get in there with the with
the black officers well that's tricky
yeah it is it is it is tricky i like
david's suggestion of just simply uh
activating one of the rooks getting
behind its own past pawn another
suggestion that kind of sprang to my
mind was simply um to look at white's
last move and just just see what move is
available as a consequence of white's
last move and that was uh white just uh
advanced the pawn forward and uh the d5
square in the middle of the board that
was protected now it's not protected so
maybe the black knight can jump in to
the middle of the board that's one
consequence and it defends okay and
magnus has played it got your magic ball
out predicting the future no it's it's
uh it was taught it was taught by a
russian grand master natalia
i've gotten her surname kasinsova
and she said that this was her her raw
hard and fast rule when she was playing
very very quickly and she would just
simply look at the ponies last move and
think right what can she now play as a
result of that move and then calculate
that one first and then it was good that
was good yeah i must admit though i
don't like that move at all um yes the
knight can jump in but what's that
knight actually doing is supe it's
really loose and actually the black
queen is the only defender and pregnant
are now trying to kick away the defender
of that black knight so the the queen is
under fire from this white bishop
the queen can't move there's no safe
square that you can go to that maintains
the protection of black's knight in the
center so you only have two options
really you have to block this attack
with a black pawn or you have to use the
black knight and capture white's bishop
in the center with check the dark square
bishop
but that trade
would lead to opposite colour bishops
but this time if you compare the
remaining bishops white slight square
bishop decent piece attacking the black
queen black's bishop now blocked in um
so i think that trade would help
president get to safety
and i'm not seeing a way black can keep
the extra pawn i think black should have
just invited the remaining pieces into
the party the black rooks were doing
nothing the black knight was okay but
the black rooks were doing nothing so
maybe it was more important to
prioritize those pieces
this is what makes chess so complicated
because you know there's no hard and
fast rules what works in one position
doesn't work in another position and i
have to say i i fully agree with david's
point because uh i mean the move that
kind of sprang to mind was actually just
picking up the pawn and blocking the the
light squared bishop's attack on the
queen but then oh look at the black
bishop it's just sat there and it would
never ever get out so easily i mean it
wants to be on that long diagonal but it
wants an open file yeah but also if you
push forward juventus suddenly the
bishop might just slide back and if you
look at the dark squares suddenly
there's a pin yeah this diagonal exactly
really loose you have no influence on
the light squares for black and yes you
might see a trade but okay the rook is
hitting if you're careless now and put
the rook on the wrong square and the
bishop's going to come forward and pin
and win uh the black queen so yeah some
danger in magnus's position and as
mentioned uh in the current position the
black queen under fire she can't move
because she has to stay protecting her
knight there's no other safe square and
uh if you have to take off this bishop
it's a check so you don't lose your
queen then suddenly no matter where you
put the black queen now this pawn is
going to drop off this has actually
happened this is the current position
black gives a check but this is easily
blocked by white's rook and again
problems with the queen it's almost out
of squares you only have is it one safe
square here okay he's gone back to the
only safe square and now this pawn is
indeed dropping note how the black rooks
want to defend this pawn but the white
bishop has controlled this key square
so pregnant are doing everything right
and if this pawn falls i think he will
be able to at least hold the game
the only thing the only bad thing about
white's position now is the king
slightly open still is any result
possible here still anything possible uh
magnus could convert this uh if he can
keep hold of his pawn but i don't think
he will be able to that's the problem
and if he loses this pawn then suddenly
white's bishop has mentioned better than
the black bishop black bishop just
purely a passive piece right now
you know i really do like
pragnanda's position
and
he's turned it around in my opinion
because his bishop is better than the
blacks bishop and uh this is what counts
when it comes to opposite color bishops
but magnus he's being resourceful as
ever you know he's really trying to
delay pragnando winning the pawn look at
this last move by uh by pragnanda he is
fearless this teenager um there's
actually a pin on the second row now and
we've talked about this in the past
rook's on the second row for black
that's where they want to be there's
normally targets there's pawns there's
kings to look at but he doesn't care he
just steps forward with his king leading
from the front and uh this king now is
off the second rank so this rook is once
again released from the pin and uh the
threat is renewed of taking this pawn
and he's not scared of advancing his
king because at the moment at least
temporarily there are no attacking
pieces around it and it's also guarded
by a lot of pawns this pawn this pawn
this pawn and the bishop's doing a great
job as well
of just keeping that white king safe
it's
normally what we don't recommend
advancing your king so far forward with
the queen's still on the board but it
just shows pregnant he knows when to
break the rules when to follow them all
right
and uh juden from forest wow a huge win
for him against uh world number three
dingle iran and important points as well
for from forest in the fight to qualify
for the knockout stage that must be um a
big win for him
against one of the best players in the
world
just like it was for pregnant a month
ago when he won against magnus carlsen
with the white pieces
are we seeing in online rapid chess uh
with the black pieces or are we seeing
an online rapid just david more wins
with the black pieces i mean you
mentioned also liam lay yesterday three
wins with the black pieces
yeah um i think so uh there have been
rounds in the past actually on the
champions chess saw many black wins yeah
um i guess the advantage of the first
move is usually the fact you can choose
your type of position but in rapid chess
when things get a bit messy later in the
game
white black it doesn't really matter too
much
and uh okay meanwhile magnus with the
black pieces trying to go on the counter
he's throwing pawns towards the white
king that's good but first of all he's
also trying to annoy this white bishop
trying to kick it away from its strong
square so i'm expecting to see that
bishop maybe retreat
but
pragnanda okay he does retreat i was
going to say is he going to be ambitious
maybe move that bishop into the black
half of the board
i think if he gets an extra move he
would love to line up this white bishop
with the black king on the light square
diagonal
and uh still in the balance still
anything can happen and both queen's
still on the board is that a sign
they're both still ambitious in this
game yes and talking of ambitious
ivanka yeah it's just uh i was thinking
about it i was wondering how i could
concoct some kind of mating attack there
but uh magnus doesn't even bother
retreating the queen he's like you know
let's uh just give up a pawn draw the
king out onto the fourth row and uh
maybe the queen can retreat backwards
with some time wow and uh actually
there's a cunning trap uh behind this
pawn move it looks like black's just
giving up a pawn for free but let's keep
an eye on the players we might see a
reaction they're low on time as well
this pawn is poisoned white should not
get greedy and take it if you take this
pawn you've actually walked okay firstly
too far forward but onto the same rank
as your queen so the queen and king are
actually lined up and black can play an
amazing move now he can break this
bishop out of its cage he can capture
this pawn in the center of the board
because suddenly if the bishop is taken
then the black rook slides back and this
is what we call a pin kind of a skewer
as well
the white queen has to give herself up
just for a rook so prague he doesn't put
his king and queen on this vulnerable
rank he retreats that king and uh yeah
really well spotted there from the
teenager once again spotting all the
danger and uh planting his king
backwards and okay a couple of quick
moves the black rook trying to join the
second rank remember we talked about it
that's where the king is but pragnando
is saying no i'm blocking you out and
now he's lining up against the black
king both kings under heavy fire and uh
blacks
king sidesteps as well this one is
really heating up the evaluation bar
going in magnus's favor i think it's
purely because white's king now slightly
more vulnerable than his counterpart but
still very tense and this is the type of
position the evaluation bar might swing
just one move by either side one
careless move it might go off in the
other side's favor
yeah i have to say uh magnus is played
like a lion to keep his pawn on c3 i
thought it was doomed i thought it was
going to fall off the board any minute
and instead he's found trick after trick
to keep it on the board and now
now it's not going to be captured at all
i mean because of the two rooks facing
along
facing off against each other on the
second row and
white can't even get greedy and could
play bishop takes bourne because the
second rook will come down to the second
row and join in the attack and things
are just really going from bad to worse
i think for pragnanda i think it's about
the clock we mentioned the time trouble
um yes he's super sharp yes he spots
tactics very quickly but he's just spent
too long and he's in big big trouble now
and ivanka have you spotted something
yeah i'm just thinking can you not play
rook takes rook chat sorry not not czech
rick takes rook and after rook takes
rook queen shaq and then the queen can
slide wow across and hit the two pieces
you're right i think we've just seen a
huge blunder a huge mistake from prague
under time pressure his king was leading
from the front but the king has had to
uh just retreat and yeah there's an
immediate win i think we have to show
this because magnus can win on the spot
with a series of actually quite logical
moves simple moves just trade the rooks
off capture these rooks as your bank
mentions a check no matter where the
king goes the black queen can actually
come across now the final move is the
most difficult one to see this last
queen move but it's simple it's a double
attack hitting the rook hitting the
bishop and one of these pieces will drop
the only way to save them both is to
retreat your bishop to defend the rook
but this allows this monster
to creep in and this is a deadly check
um yeah this one is just game over it's
check you have to
trade these rooks and black is just
going to promote this pawn on the next
couple of moves magnus has ticked under
30 seconds 20 seconds left now do you
think he's going to find that
yes if he follows then he should the
formula of checks captures and threats
then he will find it he doesn't he
doesn't find it
and i think sometimes talk at the bar
yeah top players they're too busy
calculating i've been guilty of this
myself many times we calculate calculate
calculate but we forget to go for the
simple as your mankind mentions we
forget to look for checks sometimes or
captures or threats we just rule them
out because
maybe they weren't good on the previous
few moves um so that's why you have to
remind yourself check capture threat
every turn he's attacking the white
bishop with the black queen now from the
side but pregnant okay he backs that
bishop up with his pawn
i think he could have moved that bishop
maybe safely but okay we see a check now
on the diagonal whoa
yeah again the white king just in too
much trouble pregnant at no time and
he's on the defensive side it's
impossible to defend when you have 20
seconds left and now the now the black
queen comes into the e3 square and it's
uh virtually game over the queen is
gonna plonk herself on the g3 square
give the white king a check and uh
nearly
quite a few of white's pawns will fall
and now it's just about an introducing
everyone to the party i think bring that
dark square bishop into the game uh yeah
i mean as you mentioned ivanka you can
give a check with the black queen first
but the dark square bishop does join
that party and this might be the final
blow suddenly black has three maybe even
four attacking pieces the black rook
keeping an eye on the second rank the
black queen supreme in the center of the
board bishop joining the party and also
remember the rook at the top of the
board
if it can somehow dislodge that bishop
it's just going to
when he just has to move his king around
the board
it's not really what you want to do you
want to be attacking you want to be
using your rooks yeah and
i praise that king march up the board
but i think pregnant is not consistent
just not finding the right square for
his king and now he's just wasted too
much time with it and uh okay there we
go black is actually two pawns up now
and black has the attack
so finally the tension is broken on the
second rank we do eventually see this
rook trade but that rook is replaced by
a very strong pawn
and i think pragnanda is going to give
up any moment
the black rook can actually capture the
white bishop i think that's game over
instantly uh there's maybe more simple
ways to win the black rook is the only
piece left that needs to join in and
that will be it pregnant on the brink of
defeat
magnus yeah ruthless and here it came
down all to that white king you
mentioned it yeah 20 30 moves ago and uh
that's why we've got to look for
patterns if your opponent's king is
loose okay wow
magnus they're
sitting back because he missed that his
pawn could simply be captured he's still
winning though surely um he forgot that
he the white rook now covers the second
rank he thought he was giving checkmate
next move with the black queen
he just needs to calm himself and as
soon as the black rook joins in yeah
it's game over
still
he was lucky if he made a blunder a
hallucination and it didn't affect
anything and look at that
shaking his head and smiling at the same
time it's what i call a happy accident
those are very rare in chess i mean
if you make a bad move that's usually uh
very bad news they're more common than
you think yeah yeah you know
um
there we go this is a skewer the white
queen is now just
has to give itself up for this black
rook yeah like defended by its bishop
and uh okay even more brutal magnus is
going to take some pawns first next move
the black bishop is going to retreat
with a deadly check and there we go we
have a result pregnant giving up oh and
pregnant he just logs off magnus carlsen